calling is film history Kong is a knock
that's calm he's kidding around here he
represents so much in film and
pop-culture the origin of so many
special effects and what the gap modern
cinema you're literally playing with
film history they're playing with one of
the most seminal important things in
film class throat that man is king how
do you give people something that feels
fresh but not fresh refreshing it
actually fundamentally sort of impacts
the movie you're watching and a homage
to a game before the silence notorious
for the number of ships and planes that
have gone missing
I set out to tell a new story within
that mythology I wanted to take the
character take some of the fundamentals
of the world take these cannons pillars
that sort of built the universe and
twist them and remix them and play with
them but then fundamentally tells a
different kind of story within that
universe the 1954 no clear to us warrant
test they were trying to kill something
this is a 1970s vietnam war films that
also feels very modern at the same time
and yet it also has throwback elements
to a creatures and classics not
converted similar this planet doesn't
belong to us the theater is my church
and I love being a dark space I love it
when I'm in a theater full of people
like I love that experience and I Maxima
is the the pinnacle of that age species
own deserves long before mankind coming
into imax all of that wonder and
spectacle and all just comes rushing
back because you're sitting up here and
it's so in your face that you're like oh
right cuz we're going to wash this on a
giant screen and they're going to just
get sucked into this experience
I spent 30 years trying to prove the
truth monsters exist long accused the
movies big so for me I want the movie
rid of the edges in my peripheral vision
leading just passed it and there's
something about when you do that in imax
where you really just lose yourself the
way we shot all of our locations which
were all practical and going to vietnam
and putting that on a screen and looking
at kong and either the creatures and the
Holy Week it's taken to the next level
wash and I'm at the size of imax don't
be type of projection these things do
make a difference they further and
further the gap between what people can
get it home now and giving them a reason
to say I'm going to go to the theater
missus it with a bunch of strangers and
other experiences things like oh man
when's the theater it's great to me
that's just one more layer that helps
you immerse yourself in this place
[Music]
I
you